[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's brief video i've got more
exciting harry potter news it seems like
lately for the first time in years harry
potter has been topical again
mainly thanks to the release of two
separate trailers for the upcoming
fantastic beasts film the secrets of
dumbledore the film is due to be
released next month but as it turns out
that's not all we're getting in 2022
harry potter fans will also be delighted
to hear that hogwarts legacy the
long-awaited harry potter game will also
be coming out this year in today's video
we're going to be discussing the game
and an important update from playstation
on september 16th playstation dropped
the initial trailer for hogwarts legacy
on their youtube channel and to say that
the trailer got some fans excited is
certainly an understatement with over 28
million views and 763 000 likes i think
it's safe to say that this is a game
that fans want the trailer which is only
two and a half minutes long was the
first shred of new harry potter game
content that we've had in a very long
time and it showed us the wizarding
world in a bit of a different light
during a time period predating the
traditional harry potter story
the game which is brought to us by
portkey games and avalanche software
takes place 100 plus years before harry
starts attending hogwarts in the late
1800s creators of the game have also
since released press releases confirming
the game is in fact an open world action
role-playing game which will allow you
to create your own personal witch or
wizard and spec them exactly as you want
them to be
players will experience life as a
student at hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry like never before as they
live the unwritten and embark on a
dangerous journey to uncover a hidden
truth of the wizarding world okay now
that you've got an idea of what the game
is about let me address the update from
playstation
on march 14 2022 today chandler wood who
is the community manager for wb games
avalanche wrote a post on the
playstation blog entitled live the
unwritten in thursday's hogwarts legacy
state of play if you aren't familiar
state of play is a video program hosted
by playstation where they showcase all
the latest updates announcements and new
trailers from the world of playstation
this means we're going to see proper
lengthy footage from the game for the
first time
let's read out some of the article so we
know what to expect get the first
in-depth look at hogwarts legacy
gameplay from avalanche on march 17th
avalanche software and warner bros games
are happy to partner with playstation to
bring you a special edition of state of
play entirely dedicated to hogwarts
legacy
the broadcast will begin this thursday
march 17th at 2 p.m pacific time 5 pm
eastern time since we first revealed
hogwarts legacy the trailer has been
viewed over 28 million times on the
playstation youtube channel we promised
to share more this year and we're
finally ready to deliver on that promise
the show will run for about 20 minutes
featuring over 14 minutes of hogwarts
legacy gameplay captured on ps5 and
concluding with some insight from a few
members of the team at avalanche
software who are bringing the wizarding
world to life join us thursday for this
hogwarts legacy state of play on twitch
or youtube don't forget to head back
here to the playstation blog afterward
for a special post that will add a
little more context to what we're about
to show you this is an incredible moment
that we've been building towards for a
long time we can't wait to show you what
we've been working on i've been waiting
for this game for a long time and i
can't wait to review the footage if you
want to see the action as soon as
possible then pop over to the
playstation youtube channel and be sure
to set a reminder for the big reveal
like i have and that's it for today's
video are you guys excited for this game
comment down below if you enjoy the
content please be sure to like the video
and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
you